hey everyone this is gq recommends and
today we're going to be talking about
everything you need to know to buy your
first watch
today we are going to be splitting
watches up into two big categories which
really divide the purposes of these
watches so we're going to start with
dress watches and then move into sport
watches which has a much larger field of
sub-categories because these things are
so purpose-built for the job that
they're supposed to be doing i think at
the end of the day if you're buying your
first watch the only thing to care about
and correct me if i'm wrong is like you
just have to be really into the watcher
by you have to love it you're gonna
ideally wear this a lot you know no one
needs to wear a watch you have a phone
in your pocket that can do it perfectly
well so if you're gonna buy a watch you
want something that you you want to put
on every day i think getting something
that
you are happy to to see every day is so
critical especially if you're buying
your first watch a good watch is never
going to go out of style
so when you're talking about dress
watches you're talking about a very
traditional idea of a watch right this
is going to be something that is on a
leather strap typically it's going to be
a finer fancier metal you're going to
see a lot of gold when you talk about
sports watches there's so much like the
history and the provenance and the
stories behind these watches you're
going to see that a lot less in dress
watches you know that steve mcqueen
wears a certain cartier tank but it's
not going to have that same
sense of like historic achievement that
you know a rolex oyster perpetual was
like the first watch that accompanied
the first track up everest like a dress
watch isn't going to have that kind of
like mythical story behind it its whole
job is to just look really nice dress
watches like any other watch category
will come in a lot of different price
points so if you only want to spend you
know a couple hundred dollars the timex
marlin is like a really cool watch but
then you know you eventually start
bumping up to the watches with like
really fine craftsmanship no offense to
the timex marlin of course
the first watch i really like is this
launching flagship heritage the
richardson guy rojay jean-page just wore
this watch it looks great the black dial
i really like a black dial for a dress
watch because like you're out at night
you're wearing it with probably like a
black tuxedo or like a midnight blue
tuxedo so you want to have sort of no
regular suits just tuxedos just tuxedos
maybe a suit you know if you are really
dressing down for your your gala
if you're talking dress watches you kind
of can't not talk about the cartier tank
like every kind of awesome celebrity you
can think of right has has worn a
cartier tank
type every like archetype of a celebrity
that you would want to have muhammad ali
huge tank guy and then you move to like
british royalty princess diana was very
devoted to wearing her tank founder of
cartier was apparently just having his
morning coffee and he was looking at his
paper and there were these overhead
shots of these tanks like in world war
one storming this city and he liked the
overhead view that's sort of the story
behind how it got its like rectangular
boxy shape and it became so popular that
people just started replicating it's
just called like a tank style watch and
this is a watch that you know tiffany
and co had made by movado in the 40s
because cartier was like so influential
in defining the shape as one of the
preeminent
designs if you were gonna have a dress
watch it's just a timeless classic watch
now we're gonna talk about expensive
watches which are really defining in
this category the one that i really love
is this vacheron it's so defining of a
dress watch it's a plain dial made out
of gold that's a watch you know and it's
not until you get real close to it and
get a good look at it that you have a
sense of just how fancy it is it's like
a discreet kind of kind of language
right like it's it's that's true luxury
man it doesn't have any complication
it's just completely a time only watch
which i think is so traditional like
most of the cartier tanks are going to
be time only as well because you don't
need the chronographs or the busy
dials or the annual calendar even the
date it's just meant to look
beautiful
[Music]
dive watches as the name tells you are
meant for diving and they've come up
with like a bunch of different rules
that guide what is and what isn't a dive
watch it you know it has to handle salt
water it has to be able to dive at least
100 meters has to be shock resistant you
know it comes with all of these
different parameters that just to be a
dive watch you have to meet they're made
out of steel they've got a steel
bracelet or maybe a rubber strap like
these watches are designed to take a
beating so
when you're talking about dive watches
if we go like word association i say
dive watch you say submariner how'd you
know
so tell me about the the rolex
submariner it is the probably like
archetypal defining dive watch we'll use
the rolex little brother as an example
like the defining characteristics of a
dive watch on a dial are you're always
going to have this triangle at the top
the batons at three six and nine and
then the rest of them are going to be
circles because you know when you're
underwater you just want to glance at
something quickly when that started with
the with the submariner sports watches
are the most popular watches on earth
submariner is of those watches you know
one of the like two or three or four
most popular and unlike some of them has
been
one of the couple most popular for 20 30
40 years right this was like a james
bond watch at one point if we're talking
about an affordable dive watch there's
basically one name you start with and
that's seiko seiko is a japanese brand
that makes you know everything from like
a 200 watch dress or sport all the way
up to you know watches that cost many
thousands of dollars which is a seiko
prospects dive watches the like family
it lives in it's a nice not too big size
which you know with dive watches you
tend to see like kind of beefy or
bulkier watches this one's a little more
compact got that bezel to track you know
how long you've been uh underwater or uh
you know when the parking meter is going
to come up and it's got those little
hits of orange just so you can see
what's going on yeah uh in the dark or
you know water at the bottom of the
ocean that sort of thing and then
if you want to go
a little uh
fancier in the category this is tudor's
black bay which is like this is a
signature watch for tudor and tudor's a
really cool company right just a really
really sturdy stainless steel dive watch
you know this this is this is like a big
like david beckham watch right like yeah
if you are looking to get your first
watch if you want to invest in if you
want to contrast tutor like like you're
not going to find a lot of things in
that price range that are better than
that what what watch is this this is the
omega seamaster ultra g it has earned
that name this one just like the
standard size can dive to 6 000 meters
which is um outrageous but
just recently for its 2022 releases
omega put out a new version of the ultra
jeep based on the watch that traveled to
the bottom of the mariana trench in the
pacific ocean now omega can say we have
the watch that dove further than any
watch has and went to the deepest point
of the ocean
[Music]
kim tell me about racing watches
racing watches or chronograph watches or
the reason it's called the rolex daytona
is because they would give it out as a
prize for the winner of the daytona
we're talking legendary drivers
legendary cars and they also you know
like a dive watch have their own
distinctive qualities it's always going
to have a chronograph that's like
essential to this watch you know the
bezel most often it's going to have a
tacky meter here why don't we start with
this guy yeah so this is the uh the tag
heuer monaco famous racing watch monaco
is of course like famous like home for
racing and this is famously the watch
worn by steve mcqueen uh in in his movie
le mans and the story behind this is
that he was consulting
an actual
professional driver and he saw that the
guy wore a tag [ __ ] monaco so he
requested that the guy handling props
and costumes get him a monaco too what
else we got we have another
striking navy blue watch here when
you're talking about watches the omega
speedmaster is one of the most iconic
watches because it went through this
rigorous testing from nasa it was the
only one approved for in-flight travel
and worked out well the time for them
because they got to be the first watch
that went to the moon so when you want
to talk about like the top end of the
market boy can we ever do that right i
think we could call the rolex daytona
one of the most popular watches
on earth yeah the last couple years you
know paul newman wore a specific
variation of this watch and when it came
up for auction a couple years ago it
sold for it set the record at the time
for like almost 18 million dollars which
like that's what we talk about when we
talk about sport watches it's not
selling because like it's gold or the
complication or anything like that it's
sold like that because it has this
amazing history inside of it this is
there's a daytona that's like the john
mayer daytona yeah then the green dial
the money green the john mayer and the
paul newman what they have in common is
that when they were first released
people didn't really like them that much
which is part of the reason that the
specific paul newman is so desirable
because because people didn't like it as
much rolex didn't make as many of them
and now 30 40 years later they're a lot
more difficult to find paul newman also
famous for his song your body is a
wonderland yeah
[Music]
all right so now we're going to talk
about pilot watches pilot watch is going
to have like big
huge numerals they're also like for the
gloves they typically have like really
big crowns because like if you have a
gloved finger and you're trying to like
we're talking like like exposed cockpit
flying basically right this is like if
you're flying these are these were
designed for pilots who like when they
were flying were in the elements yes
we're in the elements yeah so a couple
of the more popular pilot watches
breitling is a brand sort of like
famously associated with aviation right
yeah they made watches for like
different pilots associations you know
if you are into a dial like that like
super design heavy dial this is like an
old-school computer
exactly and do calculations on it you
have people who are like really
dedicated to breitling i think it's
cultivated like such a cool fan base of
like jerry seinfeld loves these watches
which makes sense because there's
breitling for bentley breitling does a
collaboration with a motorcycle brand so
you get also like a lot of automotive
stuff in here i see where jerry
steinfeld kind of like falls into that
harrison ford like loves breitling too
which that makes a lot of sense he's
like a hobbyist pilot fate yes famously
style another really
fun brand when it comes to pilot watches
is belle ross which actually would like
they made all their dials inspired by
you know what you would see on the
dashboard of a cockpit so like they kind
of just lifted that straight from a
plane and like made it into a watch it
looks like a gauge right yeah exactly
right one brand when you're talking
about pilot watches that's important to
bring up is iwc they make this iconic
big pilot's watch it's like so
emblematic of what a pilot's watch is it
has the the big crown on it has the big
legible numerals it has another big
feature of a pilot's watch is a the
little triangle at at 12 o'clock because
if you're upside down i guess in an
airplane and are like trying to orient
yourself on your wrist like you always
know that like that's the top of the
watch where that triangle is the sign of
a great pilot's watch is that like you
know denzel washington and flight
flipping the plane upside down would be
able to to read it right yeah exactly
[Music]
the last big category that we want to
talk about when it comes to sport
watches is
field watch is super super purpose-built
like the explorer ii which is made
specifically for spelunking so the whole
thing is like designed with a luminous
hand so that like when you're deep in a
cave like really specific tools so that
if you're diving a cave you have like a
watch to go with it you know military
issue watches too right like tend to be
field watches you know sort of like
khaki green
nylon strap really tough hard wearing
like one of the more popular brands
marathon it's a really inexpensive watch
and they did a recent collaboration with
j.crew but like people didn't know about
it because to this day like 90 of its
business just comes from government
contracts this is what the military
wears they wear a marathon watch because
it's hard wearing and durable and it's
not fussy because you just kind of want
to know the time set it and forget it
yeah hamilton famous american brand
right you know super sturdy reasonably
priced you're going to get a mechanical
watch that's going to be super solid
um you know great investment if you're
looking for a first watch a
white t-shirt and jeans kind of watch
you know also in the mid-range category
again another one of those great french
names i love pronouncing mall brawl this
geosphere watch that has the two
subdials are actually dedicated to
showing the northern and summer southern
hemisphere and if you see this thing in
action those little
pictures are actually like rotating to
try and i believe what it does is tell
you about
the time zones and so you can keep track
of
you know what the time is in every
single one of the time zones incredibly
cool and and and obviously the the bezel
instead of having numbers has
the the four you know uh cardinal
directions right so you if you i think
you probably need a compass on you but
you can adjust to like point it in
roughly that direction you can just
follow your right that's something that
you would want for a field watch if
you're just like out in you know no
man's land you get a lot of stuff on on
the bezel right like you look at the
explorer too right which is rolex's cave
diving watch and that's got the 24-hour
bezel and so it's got a gmt hand like
the other gmt watch and you can use that
for another time zone or you can use it
if you're going to be underground for
more than 24 hours to figure out how
long you know if you've been there for
inside 12 hours or over 12 hours because
you can only go around once yeah if
you're in a cave you don't want to be
like is it am or pm famously rolex
explorer to wear prince harry and but i
mean you see
like just really fashionable people are
attracted to the rolex explorer too it's
such a funny thing that like a watch
made for spelunking also is like megan
rapino and like valenciaga wants to wear
a rolex explorer ii with that outfit i
think it's like
such a handsome watch
[Music]
every watch we've seen here you could
have worn 50 years ago probably and you
could wear 50 years in the future i
think that's another just beautiful
thing about watches is that it's an
investment you're buying it to wear it
for for a long long time and either to
to pass that thing down or to trade it
in for the the next one that you love so
that's how to buy your first watch thank
you guys for for
watching
[Music]